first off for you with the HPB we have
the waves white this is made by Las
Harris Juan which is Eric wareheim's
company it's the wave series that's
something he does Just For Cans it's a
blend of gruner Chardonnay and Shannon
delicious gonna go well with the
fattiness of debris and the herbs and
the butter Cheers Cheers Stephen
[Music]
okay oh that's nice let's eat the
sandwich bread butter Brie
that's terrific do you prefer sandwiches
that have lots of stuff in them or
sandwiches that have not a lot of stuff
in there because honestly I go back and
forth but I kind of think this is the
superior proportion of the sandwich like
Simplicity good ingredients uh yeah and
every little component is perfect
excellent butter cheese ham all in one
convenient package a sip of refreshing
tantalizing wine I'm drinking it like
Sprite definitely feeling this wine